look incredible your grog crowd did you
guys see all those people up there
they're just waiting there's something
it's a big night for you too
it really is it's a big night for you
too I mean everybody here has been so
excited and so happy and so supportive
and just rooting for you guys are you
ready for us all to see this oh my god
baby
and today you both are incredible and
I've seen the first three episodes
I'm feigning for more I need more I
wonder though Jen do you think this
could be kind of a little bit of a ship
for you will you take on more darker
roles are you are you missing that
comedy bang because I like a complicated
broken kind of baddie well I did I do I
don't think she's that bad a jar we'll
see I mean it's all in there and we just
got to find the right opportunities and
the right scripts I think you're right
now that I think about it more I mean
when the layers start to come back on
her and now that I'm at the end of the
third episode I'm really I kind of took
my breath I'm like okay here we go at
the end of that one you know for the
both of you guys cuz I'm thinking where
is this gonna go and I didn't know and I
also think before you recites I like the
dark hair I like it kind of gave me June
Carter vibes a little bit you know you
know back so I'm just wondering for the
both of you guys do when you're when
you're now you're in it it's good we're
about to see it what do you hope we all
kind of take away from well well first
and foremost need to be under change too
I think everyone will walk away having a
lot of questions and and I think it'll
spark a lot of conversations which is
something we would hope to have happen
and create some awareness and people
sort of check them
their own doors we in our world of
competitive journalism we want the big
get that big interview that's what we go
after so if you were actually doing what
we do for a living who would be that big
get for the both of you guys pretty big
get return to television antennas bagged
got each other so we're good we get to
ask each other where everyone whenever
wise okay so this one here broke the
Internet
she broke instagram yes you broke
Instagram a couple weeks did you think
you were gonna break Instagram serious
[ __ ] I don't know what it is that I
actually broke yeah what did you did you
really think you were gonna get that
money you were I know you were saying
for a while come on Jen come join me the
other day I was like - is excited we
were with a just in the other and he
said he was one of the people that got
caught up in the glitch but then you
said are you following me and he said
yeah I am following you was there
anybody else any other celebrities were
you like why aren't they following me
because I got caught in the glitch - you
did yeah lots of people did well I don't
know of this glitch you speak up but I I
know there was no one else that I yam
could you imagine if I just are calling
all my friends are you following me
people do that they do
[Music]